We could end the pandemic as a pandemic by
the Fourth of July if we took action right
now.
Wouldn't mean we have no new cases, certainly.
But we could end the pandemic phase.
I guess we would call it.
And I know that many of you know, we've already
missed a number of opportunities to do this.
Back on March 5th, I'm being very generous
by looking at March 5th.
We had all the information we needed about
the spread of the virus.
We should have taken immediate action.
Donald Trump should have said to all 50 governors,
listen, we need a 50 state stay at home order.
We have some very, very difficult days ahead.
But we will be better off if we all do this
now instead on March 5th.
We did nothing on March 5th.
We ended up doing only five hundred or so
tests by March 15th.
We were still only doing about a thousand
tests a day.
By March 25th, we were finally up to 80000
tests, which was still not nearly enough.
We were so behind.
And still to this day we aren't doing enough
tests and we don't have any federal contact
tracing initiative.
So opportunities have come and gone.
But once again, we have an opportunity in
front of us to deal with what we are dealing
with right now and we could be in very good
shape nationally by July 4th.
Alex Tabarrok and Pooja All Hiver wrote a
really good piece in The Washington Post outlining
the bipartisan, bipartisan plan that they
participated in putting together.
And it's important that this plan considers
the medical and the economic.
I've been taking the economic seriously from
day one.
The right has been having a grand old time
framing leftists as not caring about the economy,
as not caring about unemployment, not caring
about economic destruction.
The truth is, I and most serious leftists
have been concerned from day one with the
economy.
And the reality is that six months of rolling
dock lockdowns in some parts of the country,
some open, close, open, close.
That's not going to be good for the economy
either.
There's a plan that's been written and the
test the testing element is a big part of
that plan.
We need to dramatically increase testing.
How innovative.
It's not it's not surprising, but we are still
not testing enough.
But the test levels are very specifically
outlined by this plan.
We need to be testing everyone who has symptoms
and all of their contact contacts and have
enough capacity for what we call surveillance
testing.
People just go in even without symptoms because
there is such such asymptomatic spread.
We need everyone who has the disease and their
contacts to self isolate.
We may need hotel rooms for people to be able
to self isolate depending on their situation
at home.
We may need stipends for people who are self
isolating while they cannot work.
And what the plan does that is really important
is it divides the country into three types
of zones green zones, yellow zones and red
zones.
And the plan acknowledges, which a lot of
right wingers want, that rural Montana doesn't
have to do the same thing that New York City
needs to do.
Green Zone would mean fewer than one in 36000
are infected.
You can do large gatherings in green zones.
You don't need a mask in green zones unless
you are part of or around folks who are in
vulnerable populations.
You need one test per day for every 10000
people in green zones and five contact tracers
for every hundred thousand people.
That is not a lot for the green zones.
Now, right now, there are not very many green
zones.
Two weeks ago, we could have had 19 million
Americans in green zones based on our testing
levels.
Right now, we don't have any active green
zones that are meeting these requirements.
Then we get the yellow zones.
Yellow zones are for most of the country right
now.
Two hundred and ninety eight million Americans
right now would be in what we call yellow
zones.
That's where the disease prevalence is, somewhere
between point 0 0 2 percent and 1 percent.
OK, in the yellow zones.
The economy can reopen.
Mandatory masks for everyone.
And you need twenty five hundred tests, tests
for each daily death.
Plus much more contact tracing.
You need to have enough contact tracing to
contact every person who's been in touch with
an infected individual within 12 hours.
Why within 12 hours?
Because if you wait three days, it's too late.
And those people have been going around potentially
spreading the disease.
So, for example, based on the last few days
of deaths, New Jersey would need 250000 tests
per day.
But Maryland would only need eighty seven
thousand tests per day.
These are much bigger numbers than what we
have.
But these are not cartoonishly high numbers
based on on the models that we've seen.
So you've got your green zones and your yellow
zones, then you've got your red zones.
Red zones are more than 1 percent of the population
is infected.
Right now, there are about 30 million people
in that situation.
That's just under 10 percent of the country.
So in those red zones, you have everything
that the yellow zones have in terms of testing
and tracing.
But you also have a stay at home order if
you follow it.
The red zone becomes yellow relatively quickly
by four weeks and most analysis and then you
move to yellow and then the whole country
could be at minimum at yellow.
By the Fourth of July, that means the whole
country could be open, although yellow zones
would still have more precautions like mandatory
masks and we could be at green by the end
of the summer.
We're not even close on testing.
We're now testing about three hundred and
fifty thousand three seventy five thousand
a day.
We need somewhere between three and five million
And based on current numbers, we're nowhere
near that.
This can be done, but we're way behind.
If we started today, we could be in mood.
Pretty good shape for moving red zones to
yellow and yellow to green heavily around
the Fourth of July.
Seems to be no political desire at the federal
government trumps acting like we won.
He's talking about superduper missiles.
But this is a plan that works.
Test, trace and isolate North Korea.
I'm sorry South Korea succeeded with it at
the earliest.
New Zealand did it.
Taiwan did it.
Greece had a milder version and they still
did it, although it took a little bit longer.
Greece's is looking at opening up for travel
very, very soon.
Prevention is cheaper than the cure.
Testing is cheaper than both the economic
destruction and the costs of treating way
more sick people.
Here's another plan.
The plan is based on right now.
It's mid-May.
We could do this.
We could be in very good shape by July 4th.